[Music]
good morning John it's Tuesday February
20th how do we always say good morning
it's never morning when I do this it's
never morning when you see this it's
2:18 here that means it's 4:00 o'clock
there Jesus I need to get crackin so the
reason why my life sucks somewhere in
here I purchased three computers in the
last week two of them went back to Best
Buy one of them I knew I was going to
take back the other one didn't have a
second hard drive Bay what kind of fancy
new computer doesn't have a second hard
drive Bay anyhow the good news is this
puppy's working now and it's working for
you John Green this is weird
looks like I'm part of the machine like
I've suddenly become the third hard
drive wouldn't be awesome if Wikipedia
could be in your brain I know kung fu
anyway this computer now that it's work
is but helping me do some Brotherhood
2.0 projects most importantly we have
our MySpace page which people are
definitely already finding out about
because we already have like 69 friends
don't know what happened so fast
you posted a little thing on sparks fly
up and boom okay it's in emboldened all
my friends too but it's very exciting
I'm glad to have friends not that I
didn't think I had friends before not
that I wasn't appreciative of our
Brotherhood 2.0 viewers before hopefully
we've become gigantic on MySpace and
then all the myspace people will become
our friends I am going crazy about what
my eyebrows are doing right now
whoa trying to get back into the swing
of things here in Montana but I haven't
been able to get on my computer's work
and my swings dependent upon computers
hoses thrown off my groove they've
thrown off my glove anyways I am
absolutely amazed at the response to my
survey that survey post has over 53
comments and over half of those are
surveys and then on top of that they're
surveys on Brotherhood to calm their
surveys on other posts they're serving
some people's websites there's audio
surveys there's video surveys speaking
of which who the heck is Tom John I did
not know that we had a secret brother
named Tom he seems like a really nice
guy though hi I'm Tom I'm your third
brother you've never met me or her
of me I have a degree in chemical
engineering and a wife and some kids
surprised to add to my computer
frustrations iMovie keeps locking up
before I save because I'm stupid and I
haven't been saving so I'm just gonna do
this and finish and say bye because I
need to eat something
and Terfel annoying we'll see you
tomorrow